so welcome to this talk I think this
will probably the a very boring talk to
most of you since you're at this
workshop so where I stand promise that
you'll give it up pouring talk and
didn't really keep I can anyway I'll
start introducing cryptocurrencies
explaining the basics of Bitcoin what
our transactions what is the blockchain
even if you've already seen it quickly
what is consensus or in other words how
can everything that we've learned about
consensus so far we used to to create
the cryptocurrency and in the second now
I'll talk about a little bit more
advanced things in particular how the
concepts that we've learned about during
the first days of this bootcamp can be
applied in particular your knowledge
proofs
snacks and so on to improve on what
Bitcoin gives us in terms of anonymity
scalability and expressiveness but first
let's start with some history where did
it all come from classical Akash how did
cryptographers think about these
concepts like in in the 80s so before
Petco and ecash the goal of Akash was
really to have a digital equivalent of
physical cash so the economic model was
basically the same as with regular
currencies so it was the concert was
introduced by David charm in this paper
in the 80s where he also proposes the
concept of blind signatures
actually instantiating it very visionary
so the model is that you have a bank
that emits coins and Alice can go to the
bank and withdraw a coin and her account
gets debited you can then spend the coin
with merchant Bob and if Bob brings back
this coin to the bank he gets his
account credited so what we want is some
digital object that's hard to produce
like physical coin so using cryptography
we have such a concept which digital
signatures the problem with digital
signatures or with any digital object is
that contrary to physical objects even
if they're hard to create they might be
easy to copy so the the main problem
with all these ecash schemes was to
solve the the main task was to solve
this issue of double spending how can we
prevent Alice to take her coin spend it
with Bob and then take the same coin
again and spend it with Charlie which
would not really yield a reasonable
currency system and the the main
preoccupation at least in the 1980s and
with everything that became that came
before Bitcoin was anonymity how can we
protect Alice's anonymity in the system
how can we guarantee that the bank does
not know that this coin that comes from
some say shady shop was spent by Alice
so digital signatures I guess all of you
know either the key generation algorithm
that gives you a secret key and a public
key with the secret key you can sign
documents just create the signature
which is then verified using the public
key so David Sean's idea was and they
should be unfortunate so David Shaw
Tom's idea was what he called blind
signatures so can we have a protocol
where we have a signer that holds a
public key and the user that wants to
obtain a signature on the message M
without the signer learning the message
okay so and it turns out that if we have
something like that then we actually
have a basic system or electronic cash
which works as follows
so when Alice wants to withdraw a coin
from the bank what she does is she
chooses a random serial number she then
runs this blind signing protocol with
the bank so she obtains the signature
from the bank on the serial number and
that represents her coin spending this
coin is very easy to cheat just sends
this coin consisting of suriname and
signature to the merchant and the
merchant can deposit it back with the
bank so how does this very simple scheme
prevent double spending well the
merchant will only accept this payment
after asking the bank whether that
particular serial number had already
been spent and only then give out the
goods so double spending is solved by
having online verification and anonymity
follows due to the properties of blind
signatures so this was a very quick
introduction of what electronic
currencies or electronic cash at least
looked like before a Bitcoin so there
were like David Tom had this company
called digit cash but somehow it never
led to widespread adoption now then few
decades later Bitcoin arrives and
becomes the - arguably most successful
ever digital currency
but changes the the approach quite
drastically so there's no more
centralized authority that issues coins
everything is decentralized there's no
bank there is hard-coded inflation which
I guess is something orthogonal to how
the system works but which arguably led
to early motivation of people to invest
in Bitcoin and ultimately to its success
and contrary to all the cryptographic
key cash before there's no strong
guarantees for anonymity so the notion
that we get this pseudonymity how does
it achieve that it maintains a public
history of all transactions so instead
of having a bank the checks which coins
have been spent now this is public and
distributed and guarantees consistency
and by using consensus mechanisms
there's no trusted authorities at all
okay so I guess it's hard to explain how
Bitcoin works because there are several
components that are combined in a very
clever way and one component depends on
the other so I guess we have to start
somewhere and that somewhere where a
start is the public ledger and let's for
now assume that this there is an
authority that everyone trusts that
maintains this public ledger and they
will publish updates of these Ledger's
so the the ledger just contains all the
users and their account balances and now
if Alice wants to spend the coin that
she owns and give it to Bob she will
just contact the authority and say
please send this coin to Bob the
authority will produce an updated
version of that ledger so that's
basically I guess this if you have a
trusted Authority it's the simplest
banking system magical
so the way Bitcoin works it's it's a bit
differently namely that there's no
notion of accounts and account balances
but what it instead does
so the the entries in these Ledger's are
transactions which basically leads has
the same outcome namely now if Alice
wants to transfer a one Bitcoin to Bob
it's not that we can look up whether she
owns it but we can look up whether she
has received it at some point so if
Charlie gave L is a Bitcoin at some
point then she will be allowed to
transfer it to Bob and this is how
transactions in Bitcoin
work
so if you want to spend something you
reference the transaction where you've
received that something but what happens
if Alice does not want to so if Alice
has a Bitcoin and she only wants to
spend half of it to Bob then the way
Bitcoin works you always have to
basically consume the whole transaction
because that makes handling double
spending easier because then you can
just say whether a transaction has been
consumed or not so the way we get around
the problem of spending all of it is
that we allow a transaction to have
several outputs so what Alice would do
is she would spend half a Bitcoin to Bob
and half a Bitcoin back to herself
and as you can later reference this
transaction output and spend this money
too
so there's no notion of accounts in the
blockchain the only type of information
in this ledger for now that is stored
there are transactions
so actually for now we've assumed more
than an authority that publishes the
ledger from time to time we also
basically assume the people can talk to
this authority that this Authority will
say yes you are Alice you're entitled to
spend your money
so how let's first solve the problem of
how users identify and this is done
using the cryptographic concept of
digital signatures so if we want to
simplify how Bitcoin works then we could
just think of a public key corresponding
to a coin of a digital signature scheme
and whoever owns the private key that
goes with it
owns this coin so that's the definition
of owning a coin knowing the private key
associated to it
so Alice owns this public key PKI if
it's in the ledger if she wants to spend
money to Bob then Bob let's say creates
his own public key pkb and Alice will
then sign a transaction that says
transfer the value from pka to PKB so
now I've already got rid of identities
all those left are public keys and this
is the notion of anonymity or
pseudonymity so again we have this issue
of double spending how can we prevent
Alice to spend her coin with Bob and
with Charlie well we're still assuming
that we have this authority that takes
care of everything
so the authority will accept payments
new transfers only if Alice has that
money in that she received it at some
point and in it does not yet any
transaction that has spent the money
any questions so far
I just I'm not telling
Numan sexy anyway so now interesting
part how do we eliminate this Authority
how do we decentralize this concept so
we have this Authority the checks
validity of the transactions and is that
publishes updates of these Ledger's this
ledger from time to time and the concept
that does this for us is the blockchain
what is the blockchain is basically a
different way of structuring these
lectures or instead of having a ledger
to which I always append transactions I
just append blocks of transactions to
this chain
how what is what do these arrows mean so
what does it mean for this chain to be
chained together that's done using a
cryptographic hash function
cryptographic hash function is a
function that is compressing so whatever
size of document you put into it the
output will always be 256 feet long and
it should have some security properties
so typically we want small modifications
of the inputs to lead to big
modifications of the output or in
another in other applications we assume
that the output really looks random it
should be hard to go backwards to find a
pre-image
but the property that we that bitcoin
basically needs ok so here's an example
of if I may use char 1 because the
output is shorter if you hash the
sentence you get this hash value if you
change one entry you get something
so a property that Bitcoin is from hash
function is that if I want to find an
input to the hash function so that the
output lies in a certain sub sub set of
all possible hash values then the best
way to find such a document is to
basically keep trying hash values
there's no shortcut to to finding such
such an input
okay so this means that so this effect
of small changes leading to big changes
in the output or leading to changes at
least for computational adversaries has
the following effect that if I have such
a blockchain so what's the blockchain
it's blocks where each successive block
contains the hash of the preceding block
so if I change something here then the
hash value will be different here so
this block will be block will be
different and that propagates through
which means that if I change something
somewhere
I will change the last hash value so
this can act as a basically the
fingerprint for the whole chain
okay so how is this blockchain used in
Bitcoin so what happens if Alice wants
to send her money to Bob she will create
the transaction she will then broadcast
this transaction to everyone and someone
will see who will take new transactions
put them into a block and create a new
block and appended to the blockchain but
who does this so the the goal was to
have a completely decentralized system
so there's no authority that we can that
could take care of this there's only
users and everyone is equal so one idea
we could do is just pick a random user
and let the user add the next block and
if enough users are honest then this
should lead to consensus except that if
it's completely decentralized and we
don't have any means of authentication
there's also no means of there's no
concept of what the user is so if I have
an adversary you can just pretend to be
a billion users and then if there's just
a lottery that picks a random user the
adversary would almost always win and
could subvert the system so that's
called a civil attack so to prevent this
the concept of proof of work was
introduced and
yes basically a concept that predates
blockchain so it's one of these
ingredients that existed that Nakamoto
basically combined in a very clever way
to attract Bitcoin so what was proof of
work first envisioned for it was to
prevent spam email and there is this
system called hash cash that's led that
lets you do it so basically the idea is
what's the business call or the business
model of spam Isis they just send out
millions of emails because it doesn't
cost anything and if someone falls for
the trick then that's good enough but if
the spammer had to work let's say a few
seconds for every email that he sends
then this would not be a viable model
anymore so how does this work anis
appended as even spam filters that give
you credit if you add such such a header
so if you want to send me an email then
you will add a header that says X
hashcash that will have my email address
it will have the current date and it
will have a random value and now I will
only accept that email if this had a
hashes hashes to something small in
particular let's say a value that starts
with 2000 if you want to send me an
email and this most likely doesn't
happen to be very small what can you do
well there's this random value here that
you could just change and hash again and
if you still note below the target you
try again you try again what's the
probability or what's the expected
number of tries you have to do before
you get one
exactly so if it's 20 0 Stan is 2 to the
20 so that will take you let's say a
second whereas me verifying that you've
solved this proof of work is very fast
because I only have two hash ones so
there's this nice asymmetry between
someone proving work and someone that
actually has to do work and someone just
checking whether the proof is correct
so that leads to the concept in Bitcoin
called mining where if you want to if
you're a miner so you want to create a
block you want to contribute to the
system you collect you collect
transactions but then the protocol says
well this block is only a valid block
and others will only accept it if it's
hash value is below a certain threshold
and how do you guarantee that it is well
you you solve this proof of work you you
have this random nonce that's contained
in your block and you keep sampling
fresh values until the hash value of the
block happens to be small enough
so now the idea is that ya proof-of-work
prevent Sybil attacks because everyone's
chances of finding a valley blocks are
proportional to their computational
resources and not
- how many identities there
so if I'm a miner I want to create a new
block I collect transactions I solve the
proof-of-work if I'm lucky and I solve
it I just broadcast this block to the
network so what do other - - that's what
the protocol specifies and we'll see
that that's also a good strategy to
follow so if I receive I'm a miner I
receive a new block I check that there's
some sections in it so I have my local
blockchain I check that there's some
sections in this new block are valid so
they spent money that actually existed
in the system it contains the hash of
the last block that I have so it really
extends this blockchain and I check that
the hash value is small enough so the
miner really has solved this and if all
these conditions hold then I say this is
a valid block I'll append it to my local
view of the blockchain and if I want to
extend now the blockchain I will work on
extending it after that block
so now of course the question is finding
a value R such that this hash value
starts with 150 zeros is a lot harder
than this hash cash I showed you so why
would anyone do this because you pay
them but who would pay them if we want
to create a decentralized system where
there's no authority well the nice thing
is that what we're creating is a
currency so we can use the currency to
pay the - the currency we'll pay for its
own stability inside
so the incentive for getting people to
try to mine new blocks will be the
reward that they get in terms of newly
created bitcoins so the miner will do is
in this block he will also put his
public key and then by definition of the
protocol this public key gets assigned a
certain amount of freshly created
bitcoins how many well it depends on
what year we're in so this now I come to
this inflation this controlled inflation
or limited inflation that I mentioned at
the beginning so the protocol specifies
that for the first four years of its
existence when you mind a new Bitcoin
block then you received 50 new bitcoins
for the second four years you only get
25 and so on and this reward halves
every four years and now the current
reward is twelve and a half bitcoins so
this will approach a maximum number of
bitcoins that will ever be created
according to the protocol which is 21
million
so that was um
- next event yeah so why every feet
every three years will date well it
depends right if not because it's not
really in four years it's in terms of
number of blocks so it depends on how
fast they're really mind which brings me
to the next point so I'll quickly
mention that the question was so what we
wanted or what the Bitcoin protocol
wants is that there is a block every ten
minute that is created but now people
just work in an uncoordinated way and
try to find blocks so how can the
protocol guarantee that this happens
every ten minutes
well there's one parameter that you can
tweak and it is how difficult it is to
mind blocks so a Bitcoin does is that
every two weeks or every 2016 blocks the
protocol will check how long it actually
took to create these many blocks and
will then adjust the difficulty so the
expected assuming that the computing
power stays the same the expected time
it takes to create the next 2016 blocks
will again be two weeks
so the reason why everything actually
takes less than two weeks is because up
until now most of the time the computing
power was increasing so these two these
2016 blocks always took shorter than the
two weeks that's also why that weather
the inflation schedule is is kind of
and other questions
we say the protocol the protocol is
basically well the the specification is
if you download the Bitcoin reference
client that specifies what protocol you
should use and then you could argue
although with selfish mining and other
texts is not so clear to what extent
this is true but at least that's what we
observe it is a rational strategy to
actually follow exactly this protocol so
now you might ask but there's no clock
in this protocol so how can the two
weeks be determined well you just take
the actual time you allow for some slack
of people having non synchronous clocks
and then and then people just if someone
to calculate the new difficulty used
something is way of your own clock you
will just reject the clock so again it's
an interest of the miners to be into
their view of
is this Idol 50 the right number
phonetic I don't know so I I think it
didn't adapt it so I given this talk a
while ago and I know that in between it
definitely was less but I looked what I
looked at was the energy consumption and
that's basically back to that which
means that it's probably matter or
mining hardware it's probably around
this in a binary representation of your
yeah but I mean if you look at the
amount of hashes the Bitcoin miners
produce is just
for ten minutes I know I know but it is
a it is basically so I've seen talks by
people talking about what's the most
computation in most complex objects that
mankind has created and people argue
that it is the Bitcoin blockchain it is
the the object that most computational
power went into created
like Hama I mean I guess it's it's it's
both right computing power in terms of
how many operations but also in terms of
how much energy consumption if you talk
about like computational
[Music]
okay let's continue Google will tell us
if it's true
are you checking difficulties 10.15 T
hashes to 81 X and X X's per second okay
so it's way beyond terror any wax are an
excess how many Terra 10 to the power of
18 so 81 times 10 to the power of 18
ashes per second so it's more like 50
but they add the sturdy there's another
three to the end
okay yeah maybe I got it wrong so what
happens if there's a fork so everyone
minds everyone has the local view of the
blockchain so even if everyone had the
same view what happens if two miners
find a block at the same time but the
the transactions that they include
differ would it be a problem I claim it
would be because it would have label
double spending if we accept that both
Oh blocks because this would be a valid
block because consistency is checked
with respect to its own history and so
with this block B so that's something
that we do not want so the the way that
the protocols specify of what you do if
if there's a fork is called the longest
chain rule which says that if so if you
look at all the blocks you can find you
can construct your your local blockchain
or all the blocks that that reach you
and you take the longest branch of this
chain and you consider this to be the
state of the system and if you're a
minor then you will try to extend here
what happens if you see two blocks then
the protocol just says accept whatever
use offers
it was look if by chance they are
completely destroyed no big no the
problem would be that you want you want
the chain where every block has the hash
of the previous right so in this case
you can you can hash the two previous
and come back you know do it diamonds
yes yes there's there's actually
proposals that try to get bigger
throughput by not having a chain but
other but having a dag so yeah but of
course the problem is then it gets a lot
trickier to to make sure there's no
contradiction okay so what happens if
this is my view I'm a minor
I try to mine here if then a block
arrives this one I saw it first so I
keep mining here by the way it's it's I
could really I mean it's not because
I've already spent a lot of time mining
here that I should continue because it's
basically a memory-less process I mean
it's not that I increase my chances of
finding a block because I've already
tried for some time but I guess the
heuristic is that if I've seen it first
then a lot of people have seen it first
and then it's rush its you always try to
do what the majority does but if then
another block extends this branch of the
chain then I would switch and I would
try to extend you
so if this is let's say this is the
network of Bitcoin miners so the nodes
would be - the the edges would be their
connections then suppose we have a state
where everyone this is basically the
blockchain they see the star block is
the last one so what happens if two
miners at the same time find a new block
so here the triangle is found and here
the the nabla is found and every one
propagates this new block to the
neighbors which means that at some point
the network could be split half of the
people believe the DISA stir of have
seen this block first so they consider
this is the the last block even if they
late to see the other one and here's the
other way around okay so there could be
temporary inconsistencies however and
this is related what - what Raphael
talked about yesterday that the time it
creates on it takes on average to create
the block must be a lot longer than the
time it takes to propagate the block
because in this case it means that it's
very already these events are unlikely
but these events the fact that these
events keep occurring is even less
likely and decreases exponentially so
what would typically happen is that at
some point somewhere someone will find a
new block let's say it was in a in a
triangle camp will propagate it these
miners will see this new block and will
then stop considering the nabla block as
as the last one and everyone will reach
consensus again
so this works if the majority of the
computing power follows the protocol
whereas it completely breaks down if
this is not the case anymore so for
example if Alice has the majority of the
computing power then what you could do
is what's called the 51% attack she
could buy a car and pay Bob Spock will
then because the protocol specifies so
not immediately handover the car but say
wait six blocks which is the time that
Bitcoin recommends that you wait until
you consider a transaction to be settled
and after six blocks will hand Alice the
keys to a new car
now if Alice has a lot of computing
power more than half of it then what you
could do is she could revert this
payment by basically spending her
transaction that she's spending to
someone else and then keep mining here
and if she's got more than half of the
computing power then at some point with
almost a probability she will overtake
the honest- and now even the honest-
since their follow the follow the
protocol will switch to Alice's chain
which means that this will be the chain
that is considered to be the actual
state of the Bitcoin network and Bob
will not have his money anyway
so miners are listening for transactions
right so yeah the same transaction
appears in let's say two consecutive
blocks that are mined by different miner
yes but no one would okay so you mean if
this transaction happens here to
propagate through the network and the
first miner what so I saw it first
one add the block to the chain yeah by
the time it got to the second miner but
the SEC but the question was that what
does the second miner do does he try to
extend this chain which already contains
the block of the first miner if so he
would not take the transaction because
he would view it as illegal and if not
then it's a fork anyway and all we care
about is that every branch locally is
consistent with respect to transactions
and forks are resolved by the consensus
mechanism
I'm sorry yes as to how the six blocks
got derived I think I think that's but I
mean if you'll read the original paper
it's very like hand wavy probability
analysis of of just like what's the
problem let's say the adversary has 49%
what's the probability of still the
adversary managing to to overtake six
six blocks of the honest users and
that's I guess was considered a low
enough number to recommend that and I
mean I guess it's also probably also
contributes since its ten-minute block
time it's one hour and it makes it an
easy in one of the lectures from
yesterday where he justifies exactly the
six bucks well the six blocks are just
you just justification of
yeah but I guess it's some it's derived
from some probability being low enough
to be acceptable as a failure
probability
so we're you here yes newer yeah but I
don't think that is what person was
about five that saying yeah I mean he's
only answer was that they took it - six
how it come first to me I can still to
the minus six if we think that loss is
50% if you book a car yeah it's I mean
but that's also the nice thing is that
you can yourself decide how much risk
you want to take how long you're waiting
and yeah those are like these fast
payment protocols they don't wait that
long
[Music]
yep why do we call it the attack Chinese
well in this case it's an attack because
it deviates from the protocol right if
this happens by I mean the fact that
Alice spends her creates two
transactions they spent the main coin is
already an attack it's not something
that can happen by chance I mean it's
not I mean you could say that yeah if
some pool has more than 50% they can but
but it is but you control them Network
but you still I mean what makes it an
attack is deviating from the protocol by
creating two transactions that webkinz
that represent double spending
so the attack is not that someone can
overtake the chain because they have a
lot of computing power but they do it
because they want to undo a payment that
they had yeah it wasn't a conference
what was a lawyer that got asked if
double spending is illegal
his answer is like obviously stole money
they just won't think about all those
details you did that was panic like it's
all somebody was giving him money who
didn't give the money it's illegal I
know you can argue with us yeah I mean
yeah I agree it's uh it's trying to it's
because you're trying to undo the
person's action that makes it
okay so - now that we've seen all the
the components of it how does it work
how how does this self-enforcing
mechanism work so the miners are
incentivized by rewards so if bitcoin
has some value then there's it's
rational to to try to mine and follow
the protocol the probability of mining a
block is proportional to the computing
power so the problem of simple attack is
avoided and it is rational to mine in
the longest chain and since like if the
majority of people do that then you get
quick consensus so basically what we've
seen so far was if we had a trusted
ledger then we could use it to make a
payment system if we have a payment
system we can use it to pay miners and
using these miners using the proof of
work consensus - Nakamoto consensus
protocol we can actually avoid this
trusted party this Authority we assumed
in the beginning and replace it by this
consensus protocol so it is self
reinforcing cycle of different ideas
that basically makes Bitcoin
so if the money's created by the my home
from the beginning howdy
Nakamoto played itself mekomo Toledo's
all of the mining in the in the
beginning changes a lot then so you can
actually a since all the transaction are
public then you you know which were the
Box did not come out to mind so you
would see whether Mac Amato reappears
and tries to spend his bitcoins and
people are watching that but it doesn't
happen we just started to fake five
billion or something he says is Nakamoto
it's in the news now but I think if you
have not come out this very easy to
prove if you
okay it's um yes everything like gasping
today they in what sense can we say that
it is rational to mind the waters chain
maille clearly like this this is fine so
what would make such a statement is it
because no no it's yeah it's all it's
all this is like the hand wavy and
overview talk but I guess you could
argue with the vassilis and say that
well if selfish mind yes physical state
we can analyze under certain assumptions
for example when we have and fix
difficulty that's one setting where we
can understand why this might be
rational and we can maybe focus as an
open problem now physically to relax
some of the assumptions and then provide
that rational analysis to - was it - for
now at least we know that it has value
the beginning evil of being for it but
doesn't mean that that is the greatest
equation right so either which was
rational and
also give this room a Russian I think
you know some people are your - thank
you could you can but they do the
mothers can say anything about how
rationality which I've seen here these
games I mean I was not joking pyramid
scheme is when people venture first gain
moved and you know slowly people's gain
this their their bodies and quality to
try to explain your how these things
outside the system he knew how to answer
this I'll go with you not was it
rational to invest in Amazon and the
question that answer should be like not
whether it was rational or not this it
should be something about that was a
risky investment new to depend on your
risk tolerance or some possible world
and some possible like loss I guess it
depends on the beliefs you had at that
time either so when you talk about
Bitcoin is different from Amazon in the
sense that the best case for big Bitcoin
is something that's in Econ a filter is
a rational bubble well if you own stock
in Amazon you want to own it regardless
of whether anybody would buy it from you
cuz a Muslim will pay the dividends even
if you holding the stock Obama something
you're not allowed to ever sell it it's
still valuable a Bitcoin that you never
allowed to sell this has nobody
whatsoever in that sense different but
the dollar bill is much more like
Bitcoin than a stock in Amazon you're
not allowed to transfer dollar bill to
anybody
there's no value
so when you were nearly invested in
VidCon you were kind of betting on it
becoming something that people use for
trading and currency in the world where
that's and if you're mining now than
this you lose some speed in this path as
long as you're planning to hold people
for years it's uncertain what the value
of liquid will be neither could be zero
okay so that was a very let's say
bird's-eye overview whereas we'd a lot
of details under the rock so let me
mention some of them so actually in
bitcoin is not true that a public key
corresponds to a coin but there is
actually somehow a notion of accounts
which the Bitcoin addresses it's not
that there's a bad list like in the in
the blockchain it says nowhere which
address has how much money but you can
deduce it by summing up the transactions
so what's an address it's actually the
hash of a public key public verification
key for signatures and when you sign
then of course in order for a signature
to be verifiable you also have to
provide the public key now how do these
transactions look like so the simple
case would be if Alice has six bitcoins
she wants to spend six bitcoins to Bob
then she produces a transaction has
Bob's public key here it's actually its
address but let's forget about this for
now and provides a signature that
authenticates that these were her six
bitcoins if alice doesn't have a six
Bitcoin bill but only two to Bitcoin
coins and one three Bitcoin coin what
does she do well that she does it like
with physical cash she will give all of
this to Bob this is possible because
transactions can have multiple inputs
and luckily they can also have multiple
outputs because otherwise she would have
overpaid Bob so what you can do is you
can send the remaining Bitcoin back to
her own address and this would be the
change that she takes from this transfer
but it actually does is that this would
not be one Bitcoin but let's say only
0.9 Bitcoin because it's all about
incentives so if you want your
transaction to appear in some block then
you better pay the miner to include it
in his block because otherwise why would
you do that it only makes the block
bigger and therefore slower to traverse
the network and therefore less likely to
end up in the longest chain so what
Alice does is or what transactions allow
you to do is that the output can be
smaller than the inputs as long as
they're not bigger this transaction
would be valid and the miner that takes
these transactions per protocol
specification earns this zero point one
Bitcoin as a transaction fee so if it
ends up in this block the miner they
created that block gets the transaction
fee so just to recap what I said before
so say Alice paid Bob so Bob now owns
the six bitcoins what does it mean for
him to own it to know the secret key
that goes with this key with a with a
public key that's mentioned in this
transaction
so what Bob can do is he can create a
new transaction spend these six bitcoins
by basically referring to it so this
input says now I'm spending the output
of this transaction that's already in
the blockchain Bob has to authenticate
it otherwise anyone could do that by
giving a signature that's valid under
his public key okay so that's like the
standard type of transaction and the
other one would be the miner that made
like the wants to spend the money that
Heath he's created by creating this new
block so what he could do is remember
the the miner put his public key inside
a new block so he could also create a
new input a transaction with an input
that refers to this block and by
definition the the value of
of this input is whatever the
newly-created bitcoins were plus all the
differences of output an input which
would be all the fees that appear in
that block so this is the only
transaction then this would be 12 and a
half plus zero point
okay is it all good well I guess one of
the drawbacks of Bitcoin is that it's
very slow so it so the reason is that
there is a block size limit so you can
only fit so many transactions into one
block
the difficulty is adjusted so there's
only one block every 10 minutes so this
leads to about seven transactions per
second which for a global payment system
is very little and it can also become
very expensive so if you look back in
January 2018 when the Bitcoin had its
all-time high and people were
transacting a lot the transaction fees
went up to more than $30 so then it
became really costly to to address for
bitcoins the transaction fees please to
go to the minor there's I'll talk about
this in the second hour there's some
solutions that basically allow you to
use bitcoins to secure payments without
the payments actually all happening
inside of Bitcoin so this could be
compared to
I don't know back in the days when they
were still the gold standards the banks
or the national banks that had the gold
reserve but they wouldn't I pay other
states by moving the actually the gold
reserve party was there as as the the
store of value so this tricks how you
can do transactions that are as secure
as Bitcoin transactions but you don't
need to put everything in the blade in
the
second problem is drawbacks of
proof-of-work itself so what happened
the way in Nakamoto envisioned it was
that it will be very decentralized
because everyone that has a computer can
just use her spare CPU cycles to mine
and then if everyone in the world minds
then that's very nicely distributed and
and hard to get a 51% majority what
actually happened is that hard like
specialized hardware was created so now
if you mind with your computer and you
would actually pay more in electricity
then you would expect to gain in Bitcoin
so you need to have very big investments
to make to buy this specialized hardware
to mind efficiently and then you should
also have cheap electricity to compete
against other miners in other parts of
the world where it's cheaper so this led
to mining oligarchy which I guess
contradicts somehow this approach or
this ideal that it should be very
decentralized well I think is the most
problem at yes minor scale is is
imprinted in the software
oh no people can offer something how's
the defeat the fear the reward the
reward is what the new bitcoins that are
created that's basically specified by
the protocol the fees it's 0.5
transaction went to the miner yes if you
if you want your transaction to be its
new decides you create the transaction
you specify what is the input what is
the output the difference is the mining
fee it's up to you if you put zero no
one will take it if you put if you
really want the transactions will be
included quickly then you put more fees
then it's an interest of the minor to to
immediately
so it's a market and that's why in
January 2018 it went up so much because
there were so many transactions that
were not being processed because there
was so much demand on Bitcoin
transactions
yes oh my I mean I think the biggest
worry of Bitcoin and using proof of work
is the electricity consumption which is
I mean if you think about it there's
this website that tell you what's the
country that's most close to how much
Bitcoin consumes and right now it's
Austria so Bitcoin mining consumes as
much electricity as all of Austria which
leads to a lot of pollution
I guess Bitcoin fans will tell you is
the banking system also spends a lot
needs a lot of electricity but I think
if you compare the the fraction of what
bitcoin represents in Global Payments it
is a very much more expensive than but I
think it's still compared to what did
coin consumes marginal I mean this if
you care about your investment this if
you care about the future yes yes a lot
of people but if there's not a lot of
good kind of like with those arguments
why should actually bother you I think
so that's one argument that's actually
why it's good because all these mining
farms they've invested so much money in
their mining hardware which they can
only use for mining so that they really
care about not ruining Bitcoin and
avoiding any kind of collusions the
people that would undermine trust in the
system because they have so much stake
in it so it could also have like
positive
yeah yeah they they they want people to
trust them so let me conclude by saying
it goes against mine yeah mining pools
as well I guess it's it's related but
again yeah there were times where I
think if two of the big mining pools had
colluded they could have launched 51% to
text but again I guess it would be and
that's something which in the game
theoretic analysis we saw is not
factored into which is that it's in the
interest not to harm trust in the system
because otherwise they would they make a
lot of money every year yeah there's no
reason for colluding yeah yeah yeah yeah
but it but it's not an interest to use
this to subvert the system no no money
if I want to mine of course as if I
don't then ask if you don't have enough
computing power participate in a tool I
can get a reward
you probably cannot you have to spend
even participating in pool you have to
spend quite a bit of money and live in a
very special place with very cheap
interesting go online and try to pretty
much it this is for a Bitcoin right like
you can do these things in other
currencies I mean there's 2500 then it's
a different problem right then a 4%
attack that's become work well I mean
we've seen that the public use register
all the ledger you find a bit confident
or there but older I will not lose my
public key because I see be able to know
you need to secret key in order to spend
the money that you need the secret key
yeah exactly that's that's basically
what makes you own the money because you
know the secret key and you can create
signatures what is the solution to use
of the signature it's a big big number
so you write it down on paper you might
be the download page
[Music]
I'll keep it for you comic seven
exchange and where you get hacked just
typing okay so there's two there's many
ways so I guess the most promising
alternative to proof of work is proof of
sake which we'll hear about tomorrow
where so proof of work means that the
probability to mine the next block is
proportional to your computing power and
proof of stake it's it would be
proportionally how much stake you have
in the system that is typically how many
coins you owned or some product of
number of coins and how long you have on
there the big advantage is you get rid
of this in an energy waste but there's
of course disadvantages as well there's
plenty of so-called nothing at stake
problems that you have to overcome by
clever protocol design and you will also
have like there's no more in Bitcoin you
have users and miners and they're
separate but in proof of stake it's
basically the users that become the
miners so that could also lead to
problems or participation
and it's an addition
get rid of that and there's also other
proposals where you want to avoid when
it's a where you still want to have some
extrinsic commodity that you use like
computing power but you but it should be
something more sustainable for example
there were proposals to use proof of
space where what if you if you want to
mine then you have to allocate a certain
amount of of hard disk space to the
mining process and any proof that you've
actually done that and then you reward
it according to how much space you've
allocated and that concludes the first
[Applause]